Hello
Let's start the presentation with the topic of
printing receipts with React and creating POS with JavaScript
Let me introduce myself first
I am a developer who creates value using web technology
If there is a function that I need, I like to create it myself and release it as an open source
These days, I'm interested in the Rust language with this cute mascot, so I'm trying to use it well
I'm currently working as a front-end developer at Toss Place
You may be a little unfamiliar with Toss Place
Toss Place is a company that has created services for business owners in the offline payment market
What I want to talk about today is this receipt
You've probably paid for a service at a store
and received a receipt that looks like this
I printed out this receipt through JavaScript
How did I do this?
Like the code on the right, I wrote the receipt output code using React
Today I would like to share
with you my experience of what kind of problem I had
and how I ended up writing this code using React
One day I made POS
Does anyone know what POS is?
There are a few
If you have experience working in a convenience store or restaurant, you have probably used it at least once
POS refers to a device that looks like this
POS is a system that handles various financial and management tasks required for store operation
They say it's POS, both hardware and software
For example, when we go to a restaurant, we order food,
we enjoy the food, and we pay when we leave, right?
When you stand in front of the cashier and the owner asks for a card, you give it to him or her
There is a machine that looks a little big, put a card on it,
and after paying, click on the screen and the payment is completed,
the receipt is printed, and we receive the receipt
In the process, the device in front of the owner is a POS device
As you can see, the POS machine has a lot of complex UIs on the touchable display
The POS machine manages a lot of things, such as orders and payments,
so there are a lot of different things to print
Since I am a consumer, I only knew about the receipt
But there are orders that you can use in the kitchen
Receipts that we are familiar with
or bills going out to the customer's table were also printed
These receipts, bills, and orders are very small compared to the A4 paper we usually print
When you touch the paper, you can get a slightly different texture
This is because it is made of special paper
The store mainly uses the printer
called Thermal Printer in English
The thermal printer is a method of printing paper by applying heat to it
So when you touch the receipt in the store, you know that the material is very special
Because this thermal printer uses special paper, the maintenance cost is a bit high
It prints very quickly and does not require ink,
so it is mainly used as the preferred printer in stores
You'll hear the word printer a lot in future presentations
I think you can think of this thermal printer as the printer here
If you look at the back of the thermal printer, it is usually made up as shown in the figure
This is the power supply
This is LAN line, when communicating over LAN
and USB flash drive
And finally, there's the serial port
Some of the more expensive printers support Bluetooth as well
In the store, it is said that the POS device is mainly connected to the serial port
What on earth is the serial port anyway?
It was the first word I had ever heard in my life
I know the cereal we eat
I've never heard of the serial port
Serial port literally means serial port
It is one of the physical interfaces of serial communication
Serial communication literally refers to a method of communicating serially
USB flash drive, DisplayPort, Thunderbolt, Ethernet, etc. are all serial communication
Even USB stands for Universal Serial Bus
As the name suggests, the meaning of serial is included, right?
A serial port usually refers to hardware that conforms to a standard called RS232
Normal speed is
For example, the most commonly used speed is 115200 bps
bps is the number of bits sent per second
115200 bps is 11.52 KB per second
USB 2.0 can theoretically transfer about 60MB per second
The serial port is very slow
But the serial port is strong against noise and the interface is simple, so it is easy to connect
So, there are still a lot of serial ports in use in industrial sites
The physical interface standard that looks like this is RS-232
If you look at your old computer, you will sometimes see these standards
This model was introduced in the 1960s
In the past, it was used to connect peripheral devices such as a mouse, keyboard, or modem
I'll show you how to control the serial port with JavaScript
There's a way to use it as Node. There's a Node Serial Port library
This is a third party library
It supports Linux, MacOS, Windows, and various platforms
It is provided through the Node Stream API
There is even a method available on the web
There is something called Web Serial API that is provided experimentally
Web Serial API is an API that can handle serial ports on the web
Input and output can be controlled as readable and writable, respectively.
Each is provided through the Streams API
Let's take a look at the Web Serial API
The web serial API can be accessed as a property called serial in the navigator
In the code here, you can select the port with requestPort
And you can open a port using the open method
Here, you need to enter a value called baudRate
To put it simply, this baudRate can be thought of as the number of bits that are transmitted per modulation
In the case of a serial port, it transmits once per modulation
so you can think of 1baudRate as just the same as bps
It means that the number of bits transmitted per second is 9600
You must enter this baudRate
This is because the baudRate is required for normal communication between the two devices
Let me explain why
For example, let's talk about when data is transmitted from transmitter to receiver
This transmitter is Tx and receiver is Rx
Tx is sending and Rx is receiver
To transmit data, the voltage signal difference is used
For example, there is a positive voltage and a negative voltage
In the case of a serial port, positive voltage is recognized as 0 and negative voltage is recognized as 1
In this way, the signal can be moved, so let's convert it into a binary signal
It can be interpreted this way
But is this correct?
Unfortunately, I can't say that it's perfectly correct
For example, you can read it like this as well
In other words, the data can be read accurately only if there is a transmission speed
In order to communicate properly through the serial port,
the transmission speed must be matched between the two devices
You can come back and open it using baudRate
You can read and write data through the open port with a readable or writable interface
When writing data,
there is something called Uint8Array, which is an interface for handling binary data in JavaScript
If you haven't dealt with it, it might be a little unfamiliar
JavaScript provides a TypedArray that can handle binary data
One of these TypedArrays is Uint8Array
Let me explain a bit more about Uint8Array
For example, Uint8Array is an array of unsigned 8-bit integers per cell
For example, if I put text ab in Uint8Array in ASCII encoding,
The first cell will contain 0x61, the second cell will contain 0x62 like this
If Ga ab is included in EUC-KR encoding,
Ga will contain two cells like 0xB0 0xA1, and ab will be contained in the other two cells
Likewise, if you encode once in UTF-8,
In this way, you can check that it is put in five cells
In this way, we can handle binary data using Uint8Array
Next, I'll write the code that actually prints
I'll bring the writable interface to the port here,
encode the value of Hello World! as ASCII, and write it to the port
Surprisingly, there's no response
Is there something wrong with the printer?
In fact, it continues to accumulate in the buffer until a print command is inputted to the printer
You have to enter the printer output command
to realize that the printer has to print it out
So what on earth is the output command?
There is an output command called ESC/POS
This command language is a kind of ESC/P
ESC/P stands for Epson Standard Code for Printers
It is one of the languages for controlling the printer
The ESC/P command is usually used as an industry standard
ESC/POS is a type of ESC/P
It is a printer command system made by Epson
It is a command language compatible with thermal printers mostly used in POS
Let's take a look at the command example
Line feed, ASCII code, that corresponds to LF, prints and publishes LF
If you use ESC @, the printer is initialized
There are several commands like this
As you can see, ESC is mainly used as a prefix,
so I think the first letter is named ESC
In addition, there are various commands
Then, the reason why 'Hello World!' was not outputted earlier is
because there is no newline output, so I'll put a command that outputs this line and print it
There's 'Hello World!' and after line feed,
If you put a command to initialize the printer and print it out,
you can see that 'Hello World!' is outputted like this
We've done something easy, so let's try something a little more difficult
For example, I'm going to print out Korean
Unfortunately, the thermal printer does not support UTF-8
Because most of the printers on the market are used stably,
it says that UTF-8 is not supported
So I'm going to encode with EUC-KR
In this case, there is a command called ESC R
You can use this to specify a set of characters in your code page
So, if you enter n=13, it will be encoded as EUC-KR
Put the command corresponding to ESC R in the data
If you encode 'Hello' in EUC-KR and then print it out,
you can see that it is outputted like this
In addition to this, there are several other commands
You can cut the printing paper
Or you can change the font size or make it bold
You can change the alignment, change the size, print barcodes,
or print QR codes
By using these various commands,
you can print a printout that is close to the receipt you usually see at the store
But the code that creates the output data is very messy, right?
Let's simplify a bit more
I was thinking about printing printer data easily by defining a class called Printer
The printer objects hold data
about the command internally
If you open a new line, newLine
If you want to output text, call text and enter the value of this data
Finally, when we do getData, we will change this to Uint8Array
Using this printer object makes it very easy to print out the printer
If you make a printer object and designate the character set, or change the text size,
change the align, print the text, and do getData, printer data is easily created
This seems to be good enough to use
In fact, most of the libraries that support ESC/POS commands I found were
implemented with this interface
But I thought it has to be improved a little
I think you can think of the printed as a kind of UI
For example, if you think of it as UI that is output to a printer rather than the browser's DOM,
the existing printer is made with the code written on the left
Creating DOM elements directly, setting properties, and cumbersome procedural code comes out
On the other hand, the code on the right shows what you want to express in the UI at a glance, right?
I feel so declarative
The one on the left is a bit more imperative code and the one on the right is more declarative
We usually prefer to do it declaratively when we create the UI on top of the web browser
So, if you think that the receipt is a kind of UI that is expressed as a printer output,
I thought it would be nice to express the data to be printed with a declarative syntax
Even the code is a bit short
I was using React in my project,
so I thought that I could easily write receipt data declaratively using JSX syntax
The way to use React is
Let's say you have a receipt that looks like this
There are left-aligned text, center-aligned text, images, and lines
Divide each compartment
For example, you could treat the entire receipt as a Printer component
The left-aligned text is a Text component like this,
Center-aligned text is in the state that the align property is given to the Text component
It can be divided into Image and Line
I think it can be expressed in code like this
So, we've been able to create this JSX code,
but how do we change it to Uint8Array?
The cool thing about React is that you just declare how to draw the UI,
and the renderer puts the appropriate data at the right time and renders it in a state that suits the environment
For example, react-dom renders to DOM in the browser environment
In the case of react-native, it renders with Native UI
If you take advantage of this, you can render in a form that supports ESC/POS commands
in a printer environment with a little customization on the renderer
In other words, you can think of a renderer
that takes a random React element and converts it to Uint8Array
If you use the render function, you can change the receipt code you created earlier to Uint8Array
in this way and write it to the port and print it
Let me print out a complicated receipt in this way
It's printing some text and barcodes
Using React like this,
you can write it in a declarative form like the code on the right
And I thought it would be nice to be able to easily predict
what will be printed on the left by looking at the code on the right
How can we implement the render function?
The printer output does not require a render function that is complex enough to require scheduling or readjustment
I thought we could just go around the React child nodes
and generate output commands for each node to output node
So, we declare a function called print that generates an output command for each component
And when the render function receives a React element as input,
All you have to do is run this print function while traveling around each child node
Then
Since data must have been accumulated in the printer after going around,
just getData will return the receipt output data in the form we want
The actual implementation is a little more complicated,
but conceptually it can be seen like this
There is one more good thing about writing receipts like this in React syntax
That is, rendering is possible even in an environment with DOM
For example, when drawing on the DOM,
you can draw in this way using the renderer provided by react-dom
Or, if you need a printout,
you can print the receipt like this by rendering it as it corresponds to the printout
In other words, if you style it appropriately,
you can easily create a preview of how the receipt will be printed in the browser
I did some interesting work by customizing the renderer of React in this way
There were actually several packages that were made by customizing the renderer
Besides react-dom or react-native
In the case of rendering using react components in the terminal environment, there was a library called ink
If you want to render PDF, react-pdf
The one I introduced today is called react-thermal-printer
I made it open source on npm and distributed it
One of React's slogans, Learn Once, Write Anywhere,
I think it was a very relatable experience
This is what I wanted to share